the sacred city of caral
the remains of the oldest civilization
in the americas
have been standing here for 5 000 years
almost unscathed until now
farmers in the super valley are sowing
crops on the doorsteps
of these ancient ruins and squatters
have moved in
archaeologists who work here say they've
received
death threats we live in uncertainty
this is far away if we call the police
they take long to get here
we don't know if the squatters will harm
us
in pedu illegal land seizures are common
and lucrative
and squatters are often in conflict with
police
archaeologist ruth shady was shot in the
chest in 2002
she says she received more death threats
and when she tried to evict squatters
from at least
nine sites she got little help
we went to the police but they told us
it wasn't their priority
that we could not count on them we asked
again and they sent one officer
with one it's impossible to evict them
land disputes have been going on for
decades since being named a unesco
heritage site in 2009 land prices around
caral
rocketed from six to nearly fifty
thousand dollars per hectare
since the pandemic the archaeologists
left the site
and more squatters have moved in this is
how closed farms and urban areas
are to ruins not only in kerala but
throughout the coast of peru
filled with vestiges of pre-columbian
cultures
the area is so vast it's nearly
impossible
to protect it all this archaeological
zone is dispersed across
hundreds of square kilometers families
living close to it say they built
homes here before it was discovered and
they defend
newcomers we need a place to live
if they pay us what we invested in our
homes we can leave but they just can't
evict us
police seldom supervise the 11 sites now
occupied by squatters to evict them now
they will
have to go to court and that can take
years
some say those delays risked the future
of this ancient site
that survived earthquakes climate change
and generations of peruvians who revered
it
mariana sanchez peru